le calme semble être de retour au pays
bas après des affrontements entre
émeutiers et forces de l'ordre ces
derniers jours
ici les violences urbaines sont rares et
ont choqué et les esprits des habitants
de feuilles en ordre dans des quartiers
et les plus touchées à rotterdam
quelques jours après les affrontements
il reste encore des traces et les
commerçants tentent de reprendre une vie
normale
franck et son équipe remplacent les
vitres brisées de cet arrêt de tramway
seront les dégâts après les émeutes dans
toute la ville je trouve que ce n'est
pas normal les gens doivent mieux se
comporter
les temps sont durs pour tout le monde
il faudrait se calmer nous avons du pain
sur la planche
et les choses ne devaient se passer
comme ça normalement un tablet os mais
ron gérant d'une boutique était chez lui
lors de la première nuit des
affrontements alors que sa boutique est
attaqué
durrani son voisin repousse les
émeutiers attend le lendemain
ron barricades son commerce c'est la
première fois qu'ils sont témoins de
telles violences
[Musique]
la nuit était terrifiante mais quelques
jours après notre corps de tes risques
et soudés pour être plus forts ensemble
combined nous allons nous en sortir
premières émeutes que j'ai vu en 30 ans
te dis quelques jours j'ai vu les
casseurs des ma fenêtre s'approcher de
la bauxite pour la casse et à kandahar
et cleary je suis venu en vitesse pour
les éloigner
j'ai pris une porte pour les empêcher
d'entrer d'origine tournoi du queen's à
nice
je veux adresser un message à ses jeunes
individus
ceci n'est pas un jeu de casse et
troquer aussi c'est la vraie vie tu es
sur nos gains des 6 0
life faille au nord d'être un quartier
cosmopolite plutôt tranquille et même si
certains désapprouvent les restrictions
sanitaires
tous dénoncent les violences et les
dégradations à m'exprimer je suis
partagé je condamne la violence voilà
comprendre la colère des gens
donc je pense qu'ils veulent faire
entendre leur voix tout l'attirail spurs
je le conçois mais c'était très agité et
intense ce n'est pas normal
profil bas je le lis mal car ce pays
fait beaucoup pour ses habitants
alpro concha et ce n'est pas bien tout
ça mais dernièrement qu'on a vu ici
c'était avec les hooligans les gens
vivent ici ils ont détruit leur vie mais
c'est triste c'est une première je
n'arrive pas à croire que ce sont des
gamins de 15 saisons
je suis sûr qu'il y a des gens qui les
pousse à faire ça il ya pas mal de
choses qui ne vont pas mais je veux
rester positif malgré tout je souhaite
le meilleur à tous les besoins dans la
crainte d'un week end agité la police a
renforcé ses effectifs dans les
principales villes du pays
près de 400 personnes ont été arrêtées
et le gouvernement a prononcé un couvre
feu jusque début février